hey schön dass ihr dabei seid zdf heute
live heute mit diesem thema wie steht es
um die zukunft von afghanistan wie soll
das aussehen ein leben unter den taliban
und die mit ihnen mit ihnen verhandeln
und wenige tage nach der machtübernahme
der taliban sind in einigen städten des
landes heute am unabhängigkeitstag
menschen auf die straße gegangen zum
protest auch ein paar wenige mutige
frauen waren dabei gerade sie haben die
größte angst vor den extremisten und
viele hilfsorganisationen fragen sich
nun auch wie es weitergehen soll vor
allem seit mehrere länder die hilfen für
afghanistan aussetzen sollen aussetzen
wollen viel eher und wenn ihr fragen
oder kommentare habt dann schreibt sie
uns gerne per mail oder stellt sie auch
im stream denn wir haben heute zwei
spannende gäste wir wollen sprechen mit
der ethnologin und journalistin shiva
burin sie ist geboren in kabul in
afghanistan und mit hans-hermann dube
ehemalige entwicklungshelfer im land und
schön dass wir beide uns heute abend
zugeschaltet sind hallo
frau valerie sie sind selbst in
afghanistan geboren wir bilden dort
journalisten im land aus haben viele
kontakte dorthin was berichten die ihnen
zurzeit von der aktuellen situation
also jetzt gerade explizit die
journalistinnen die in kabul geben bei
denen hat die situation sich in den
letzten drei vier tagen extrem verändert
im norden des landes ist es anders
gewesen die haben schon früher die
erfahrung gemacht dass die taliban
wieder sichtbar oder fühlbar in der
stadt waren
und die verlassen jetzt seit ein paar
tagen nicht mehr die häuser und dadurch
dass ein
gerücht umgeht dass die taliban von haus
zu haus gehen und nach journalistinnen
und aktivistinnen ausschau halten um sie
dann umzubringen
ist ihnen gesagt worden alles zu
vernichten oder zu vergraben
redmond was die haben halt was einen
nachweis dafür wäre dass sie
journalistisch arbeiten
und deswegen ist die stimmung wirklich
sehr beängstigend sehr besorgniserregend
das hört man auch den frauen an mit
denen ich auch sprecher
die haben zwar die hoffnung dass das
nicht noch schlimmer wird die sind in so
einer situation in so einem zustand dass
sie sagen wir warten mal ab wie das
passiert bis ich das alles beruhigt wenn
bis am malen entwirrt gesprochen worden
ist und solange bis das nicht passiert
ist halten wir uns besser still genau
das ist so die stimmung im moment und
habe auch sie selbst haben viele jahre
im land gearbeitet haben immer noch
viele kontakte vor ort sind das andere
erzählungen die sie dort hören oder was
berichten die menschen die sie vor ort
kennen
ich denke dass ich wahrscheinlich mit
anderen menschen zu tun habe als
rubacuori denn
ich habe zwar viele jahre in afghanistan
gelebt und gearbeitet aber ich muss zu
meiner schande gestehen in dem land
hatte ich so gut wie nie kontakte zur
frau eigentlich fast nur männer aber das
liegt natürlich auch an der natur des
des landes also von daher ist es für
einen mann vor allen dingen für einen
ausländer ziemlich schwer überhaupt mehr
frauen den kontakt bekommen aber das was
frau wurde jetzt gerade erzählt hat werd
mir auch von meinen kontakten berichtet
ohne dass das wirklich jetzt belegt
werden könnte das also die taliban
tatsächlich schon drohungen
ausgesprochen haben
was ich aber wirklich ganz interessant
fand kurz bevor ich hier ein studio
gefahren bin habe ich noch mit einem
afghanischen ehemaligen mitarbeiter der
arzt
in kabul gesprochen der nebenbei auch
hier mal in kiel ausgebildet wurde der
mir sagte dass er doch eher erstaunt
darüber ist dass die große masse der
menschen auch in kabul sich eigentlich
darüber freut dass die taliban da sind
weniger weil sie die taliban gut finden
sondern weil sie einfach darauf hoffen
dass jetzt endlich
der krieg der von den taliban
behauptet wird seit 40 jahren ist krieg
an stimmt wahrscheinlich auch dass das
jetzt endlich vorbei ist und dass nun
ein längerfristiger frieden einsetzt
herr dube sie haben es gerade schon
erwähnt sie haben sie haben gesagt
natürlich als man ihr kontakt zu männern
gehabt aber vielleicht auch noch mal am
anfang ganz klar und transparent zu
machen was haben sie dort genau für eine
arbeit vor ort gemacht dass wir das alle
auch noch mal genau nach nebel ich gerne
in zwei drei sätzen skizzieren ich bin
2002 als berater des afghanischen
arbeitsministers nach kabul gegangen mit
nur kg herr minister nur kaffee und habe
ihm dabei geholfen
das afghanische
arbeitsministerium aufzubauen was
relativ kompliziert war aber wir haben
da glaube ich einen ganz guten weg
gefunden und dann bin ich aber relativ
schnell gewechselt von aus dem
sogenannten bilateralen bereich der
damals gesellschaft für technische
zusammenarbeit
ich bin dann hab dann die international
finanzierte und deutsche entwicklung und
von deutschland durchgeführte
entwicklungszusammenarbeit in
afghanistan geleitet große weltbank
projekte un projekte die jeweils aus den
an aus den großen organisation bezahlt
wurden aber von uns durchgeführt worden
das war so meine aufgabe und ich habe in
kabul knapp fünf jahre gelebt und bin
dann nach pakistan versetzt dann indien
hat aber meine aufgaben für afghanistan
dann sozusagen aus den nachbarländern
geleitet ab bin aber mindestens jeden
monat für eine woche zwei wochen in
afghanistan gewesen und meine arbeit wir
werden vielleicht noch auf die einzelnen
projekte kommen
fand im gesamten land statt also ich bin
sicherlich einer der wenigen deutschen
die in allen provinzen gewesen sind und
vor allem im ländlichen bereich also
auch in und in hunderten tausenden von
dörfern
über diese unterschiede wollen wir auch
noch sprechen also gerade insbesondere
wir haben von ihnen beiden bereits auf
sehr unterschiedliche schilderungen
gehört aber jetzt noch mal ganz konkret
zu der situation der frauen hat meine
kollegin elisabeth schmid heute mit
einer afghanischen
frauenrechtsaktivistin
afrikas angesprochen die sich große
sorgen auch um die frauen vor ort macht
und dem bericht wollen wir uns jetzt
gemeinsam erst noch mal anschauen
so sieht ihr afghanistan aus afrika
hassan im alter von 35 jahren frei
umwelt offenbar ihr land sagt die
frauenrechtsaktivistin die seit 25
jahren in hannover lebt jetzt fürchtet
sie könnten die taliban den frauen wider
aller rechte nehmen
frauen aus der provinz herat haben mich
angerufen und erzählt dass die taliban
ihnen verboten haben zur schule oder zur
arbeit zu gehen sie sagen auch dass
junge frauen oder witwen gezwungen
werden hochrangige taliban kämpfer zu
heiraten eine weitere frau erzählte mir
dass ihr kind gerade vor hunger schreit
weil sie sich nicht traut auf die straße
zu gehen um essen zu kaufen aus angst
vor den taliban
dass sich die taliban in den medien als
weltoffen präsentieren halten hassan und
ihr dolmetscher für reine show
die taliban behaupten frauen könnten
sich frei bewegen und ihren aktivitäten
nachgehen aber das ist nur eine falle
die taliban wollen diejenigen frauen
erwischen die bereits für demokratie für
bildung für frauenrechte gekämpft haben
wer weiß was sie mit ihnen dann vorhaben
die taliban haben sich nicht geändert
und wie geht es jetzt mit den frauen
weiter
viele frauen in afghanistan haben
bereits ihre männer verloren durch den
krieg oder durch ein attentat wenn die
taliban so weitermachen wie bisher dann
sagen viele frauen dass sie sterben
müssen denn weil die frauen keine männer
zu hause haben müssen sie arbeiten
und wenn die taliban den frauen das
nicht erlauben was sollen die frauen
dann anderes machen als sich umzubringen
die situation der frauen in afghanistan
bereitet der 70-jährigen schlaflose
nächte sie hofft dass europa das
deutschland sie nicht im stich lässt
frau was raten sie ihren kontakten vor
ort die ja ähnliches geschildert haben
ähnliche ängste ähnliche befürchtungen
was ist das was was sie denen im moment
sagen ich kann dem nur zu sprechen dass
es dass sie geduld haben sollen wobei
während ich das schon sagen das kommt
mir selber so falsch vor weil diese
frauen die ich meine das sind teilweise
wirklich ganz junge frauen die sind
teilweise anfang 20 und die sind unter
diesen umständen
geboren also selbst ihre mütter hatten
waren schon geduldig und haben
abgewartet das eine situation eine
schlimme situation sich für sie
verändert und so jemanden dann noch mal
sowas zu zu raten aber was soll ich denn
anderes auch sagen ich kann ich weiß
natürlich auch nicht wie es weitergeht
ich kann das nachvollziehen wenn die
sagen dass die angst haben und dass sie
diese ganzen gerede der taliban nicht
trauen ist ja auch nichts also dass man
jetzt wenn nicht nur nicht traut sondern
einfach die haben sich ja bis jetzt seit
diese ganzen verhandlungen auch
angefangen haben egal wo die geführt
wurden sind egal welche abmachungen
gemacht wurden sind mit denen die haben
sich an keine abmachungen gehalten und
auch jetzt in den provinzen wo sie jetzt
schon fuß gefasst haben was die frau
hassan auch gerade erklärt hat erzählt
hat
jeder hat oder in kandahar oder auch in
einigermaßen sicheren taliban sicheren
norden auch masar-i-scharif wo die schon
länger als jetzt ein paar tage fuß
gefasst haben und da machen die doch
genau das da lassen sie doch jetzt schon
nicht frauen aus dem haus und sagen wir
müssen die ich irgendwie so scharia
konform anziehen nicht ohne männliche
begleitung rausgehen wie sollen die
frauen den kabul sind die ein stück mehr
freiheit erfahren haben als die den
kleineren provinzen und bezirke leben
sich darauf verlassen können herr grube
sie hatten zuvor geschildert also es
gibt auch durchaus leute von denen sie
gehört haben die sich mehr oder weniger
freuen wenn man das sagen kann dass die
taliban zurück sind zumindest es gibt
jene das sagten sie die hoffen auf mehr
frieden frau barbara hat eben
angesprochen dass die taliban sich aber
vielleicht auch da nicht an abmachungen
halten was sagen sie dazu wie ist das
einzuschätzen ist das vielleicht aber
auch ist das land gespalten in dieser
frage wie ist das
ich möchte ganz ganz klein bisschen
ausholen dass alles was wir gerade eben
gesehen haben über die frauen ist völlig
richtig und korrekt das ist ein also ich
stelle es mir vor als ein land das jetzt
über frauen hinein bricht vor allen
dingen in den großen städten vor allen
dingen wahrscheinlich in kabul
möglicherweise auch im basar wenn ich
aber nur 20 kilometer aus kabel raus
fahren in die dörfer
dann und das habe ich nun wirklich viel
gemacht dann habe ich eigentlich dass
dort immer erlebt was jetzt zu recht für
kabul beklagt wird dass er die frauen
auch nicht alleine raus durften in den
ganzen jahren die ich unterwegs sei in
kandahar habe ich keine einzige frau
alleine auf der straße gesehen oder
unverschleiert
in den dörfern es ist noch extremer da
sind die frauen wirklich weitgehend
weggesperrt oder dürfen nur mit ihrem
mann oder im großen erwachsenen sohn
oder schwager oder onkel raus also das
land ist zumindest was das angeht schon
einmal gespalten und gerade eben in dem
film wurde auch gesagt afghanistan das
war früher ein freies liberales land
kann ich sagen ja aber bezogen auf kabul
auf dem recht des landes nicht und der
rest des landes in der in der großen
masse der dörfer afghanistans werden die
menschen das gar nicht mitbekommen dass
jetzt die taliban regieren denn die
haben da nur nicht unter dem namen
taliban eigentlich immer regiert und
immer ihre haltung und position so
durchgesetzt also das ist vor allen
dingen aber das will das jetzt nicht in
irgendeiner form relativieren ein
schreckliches problem für die frauen in
den städten die auch zurecht gehofft
haben dass es durch uns ausländer dort
besser wird
dass die jetzt wieder so total und
brutal wahrscheinlich zurück gestopfte
gestützt werden dann muss ich nachfragen
bei ihnen frau valerie diese
unterschiede stadt und land können sie
das bestätigen haben sie das auch schon
gehört ja das ist auf jeden fall ganz
klar das ist im fall von afghanistans so
das war auch jetzt in den letzten 20
jahren diese ganzen
fortschrittliche projekte die man
gesehen hat diese ganzen entwicklungen
was unter den frauen gegeben hat und
dass sie in der schule beenden konnten
jetzt nicht nur zur schule gegangen sind
und irgendwie so bis zur dritten klasse
lesen und schreiben gelernt haben ein
bisschen sondern dass sie auch
universitäten abschluss hatten das war
halt alles wirklich nur in den
großstädten das ist absolut richtig das
war schon immer so das war also das war
auch vor den taliban zeit so da hat er
absolut recht als das rechtlich aber das
regieteam
legitimiert natürlich nicht dass jetzt
frauen aus kabul oder anderen
großstädten die bis jetzt diese
freiheiten kennengelernt haben und
übrigens jetzt nicht nur in den 20
jahren in den letzten 20 jahren sondern
wie frau hat das gesagt hat als sie das
noch lebte und zur schule gegangen ist
ihre jugend verhalten der andere das
heißt afghanen die generation ist meiner
meiner eltern meiner mutter jetzt zum
beispiel die canon ein anderes
afghanistan ohne dass das militär oder
im internationale präsenz im land
gewesen wäre und insofern im das mag
sein dass da ein bisschen was sind
zusammengemischt auch ist in afghanistan
zum einen die die radikalislamischen
ansichten der taliban und zum anderen
diese ganze traditionelle
glaube und umgang mit frauen in
afghanistan also da ist irgendwie die
grenze sehr sehr weich oder sehr sehr
nah aneinander
aber trotzdem ich meine dass die frauen
in den großstädten auch
vor vielen jahren 60er 70er jahre anders
gelebt haben das war auch damals möglich
und die frauen wollen hier dass die
wollen nur dass sie wollen ja einfach
nur ihre familien versorgen können die
wollen einfach an beruf nachgehen die
zahl der witwen in afghanistan ist
exorbitant hoch durch diese ganzen
kriegsjahre und die müssen wir in der
lage sein irgendwie ihre familien
irgendwie versorgen zu können und es ist
ein 1 1
dass solche szenen solche geschichten im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert unter den
augen der internationalen
gemeinschaften da sich abspielen ist
hohen finde ich es gibt die frage hier
bei youtube von mir gibt es konzepte wie
man die frauen und mädchen schützen kann
im moment da auch nochmal frau barbara
dazu naja das war ja ein wunsch auch
schon der letzten 20 jahre dass das
ausländische militär das in afghanistan
war eigentlich dafür sich hätte
einsetzen müssen und sich hätte darauf
begrenzen sollen oder zumindest einen
hauptteil ihrer arbeit das hätte sein
sollen dass man sich um die sicherheit
einfach der menschen dort die was
erreichen wollen die eine
zivilgesellschaft mit aufbauen wollen
dass man g unterstützt das ist auch
einer der versäumnisse der letzten 20
jahre die definitiv stattgefunden haben
dass das nicht passiert ist weil was für
afghanistan wirklich ein genickbruch ist
ist ein film der mittelschicht was bei
der sowjetischen invasion war das ja so
dass viele viele millionen abgaben aus
dem land sind aus angst weil wir wussten
dass da ein krieg losgehen würde und die
komplette mittelschicht war weg und
jetzt in den letzten 20 jahren haben
sich in den großstädten ein bisschen
wieder so eine art mittelschicht
gebildet durch die projekte die es dort
gegeben hat und wenn das jetzt wieder
verloren geht ist das schlimm aber um
auf ihre frage noch mal zurückzukommen
wie man die unterstützen kann
wenn jetzt auswendig einblicke jetzt
nicht mehr vor ort ist oder jetzt bis
ende august noch komplett raus geht
bleibt es eigentlich nur dann daran
gebunden wenn man mit diesen geldern die
für afghanistan zu stillen und jetzt
wohl auch das sind wir auch zahlen schon
bekannt ich weiß ja gerade nicht was in
entwicklungsländern hilfe nach
afghanistan gehen soll dass man die
definitiv an bedingungen knüpfen muss
etwas was auch in den letzten 20 jahren
leider nicht passiert ist das für
bestimmte projekte gelder ausgegeben
worden sind und so oft hatte es
vonseiten auch aus afghanistan mit
kolleginnen oder andere menschen mit
denen ich dort gesprochen habe dass die
gesagt haben das bin ich zurück gehen
nach deutschland soll ich das da
den menschen erzählen dass die nicht
einfach das geld auszahlen sollen sollen
sondern die wirklich an bedingungen
knüpfen weil sonst das geld kommt nicht
da an wofür es gedacht ist sie haben
gleich young satz neuer und das ist
wahrscheinlich noch so das letzte wie
man die taliban irgendwie irgendwie dann
noch führen kann bremsen kann irgendwie
wahrscheinlich frau valerie sie haben
die hilfsgelder angesprochen die ihm
jetzt teilweise auch von deutschland
eingefroren werden sollen wir haben dazu
einen bericht und wollen dann auch gerne
mit ihnen beiden gleich darüber sprechen
zunächst aber der bericht von moritz
neues
afghanistan eines der ärmsten länder der
welt und stark auf hilfsgelder
angewiesen im vergangenen jahr machten
die entwicklungshilfen fast 43 prozent
des afghanischen bruttoinlandsproduktes
aus zu den wichtigsten geberländern
zählt deutschland seit 2001 hat das
bundesentwicklungsministerium rund 3,5
milliarden euro für afghanistan
bereitgestellt für deutsche
entwicklungsgelder ist das land damit
empfänger nummer eins doch nach der
machtübernahme der taliban hat der bund
seine zahlungen eingefroren die
geplanten hilfen in höhe von 430
millionen euro für dieses jahr vorerst
auf eis gelegt einzige ausnahme die
humanitäre hilfe diese wird unabhängig
von politischen aspekten gewährt um
notleidende menschen in
extremsituationen zu unterstützen etwa
nach naturkatastrophen oder bei kriegen
der appell an die internationale
staatengemeinschaft weiterhin auch
entwicklungshilfe für afghanistan zu
leisten kommt unter anderem vom
katholischen hilfswerk misereor
fast 90 prozent der afghanischen
bevölkerung seien arm
grundnahrungsmittel verteuerten sich und
zudem befinden sich rund vier millionen
menschen innerhalb afghanistans auf der
flucht daher seien solidarität und die
hilfe der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft nun dringend
erforderlich
bevor wir zu euren zahlreichen fragen im
stream kommen herr dubai eine frage an
sie was macht das mit afghanistan wenn
er jetzt tatsächlich also kein geld mehr
fließen soll
was macht das mit den menschen in
afghanistan
das geld das zumindest für so aus
deutschland fließt oder geflossen ist
ist ja in erster linie eigentlich über
staatliche und
nichtstaatliche organisationen
ausgegeben worden das heißt also das
geld wurde in deutschland an die
organisation verteilt und die haben dann
vor ort mit der mit der regierung
abgestimmte vorhaben durchgeführt aber
es ist nicht die regel dass das geld an
die afghanische regierung fließt das
wäre dann also finanzielle hilfe dass es
etwas was über die kfw läuft die
entwickler ein entwicklungs
organisationen sind für das geld
verantwortlich und achten sehr genau
darauf dass das genauso ausgegeben
werden wie es geplant ist das heißt also
wenn jetzt keine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit mehr läuft
werden wird die gez oder wird auch
welthungerhilfe und wie diese ganzen
organisation alle heißen die ja
großartig sind und auch eine tolle
arbeit für die menschen geleistet haben
in den letzten jahrzehnten deutschland
ist nebenbei seit dem zweiten weltkrieg
in afghanistan mit
entwicklungszusammenarbeit tätig die
dann kommt die zusammenarbeit nicht mehr
bei den menschen in den dörfern oder
auch in den städten an und das ist ein
verlust für die für die leute vor ort
weil sie damit dann auch ein stück ihres
lebens ihre planung für ihre zukunft
verlieren es ist auch eine frage hier
für sie direkt im chat herr grube dass
der vertrag nennt er sich bei youtube er
möchte wissen frage wenn man afghanistan
nun isoliert und nicht mit geld hilft
werden sich die taliban weiter
radikalisieren um die macht zu erhalten
davon bin ich fest überzeugt dass genau
das passieren wird also ich halte es für
absolut sinnvoll dass deutschland so
schnell wie möglich wie ein weg findet
wieder die entwicklungszusammenarbeit
mit unseren internationalen experten wie
auch mit den nationalen experten davon
haben wir sehr viele hochqualifizierte
afghanen afghanen die bei uns arbeiten
mit den wieder in die fläche rauszugehen
und ich das einfach mal so ganz
schlichte vorhaben die berufsbildung
vorhaben in den dörfern für männer und
frauen beruf der schneiderin
[Musik]
beruf des malers des tischlers als
solche sachen davon haben wir ja
unendlich viele projekte durchgeführt
seit jahrzehnten weg die seit
jahrzehnten die erfolgreich waren und
die dafür gesorgt haben dass die
menschen ihr geld verdienen konnten und
stolz abends zum markt laufen konnten um
nahrungsmittel für die familie zu kaufen
wenn wir das nicht machen wird auch die
bevölkerung enttäuscht sein und sich er
dann den taliban zu wenden das ist auch
eine erfahrung die wir durchaus im
laufenden jahre gemacht haben eine frage
an sie beide da auch also muss man dafür
um das eben gewährleisten zu können dass
da die menschen auch an ihr geld kommen
eben auch mit den taliban verhandeln
zuerst vielleicht die frage frau barbara
habe ich frage mich gerade herr duo wenn
das so in den letzten jahren gemacht
wurden ist warum hatten dann die taliban
so einen zulauf gehabt wenn die leute
geld verdienen konnten und geld hatten
und nicht die notwendigkeit
die sind doch zu den taliban weil die
genau das nicht hatten ist meine
erfahrung
naja darf ich darauf antworten natürlich
wir haben ja nicht mit den geldern die
und zur verfügung standen ganz
afghanistan erreicht leider nicht aber
in den dörfern in denen wir aktiv über
jahre gewesen sind ist diese frühe
abwanderung an die aufständischen nicht
erfolgt wobei ich an dieser stelle auch
ganz klar sagen muss nicht jeder
terroranschlag in afghanistan wurde von
den taliban verübt es geht noch
unendlich viele andere gruppierungen die
ganzen warlords alle möglichen die dort
auch alle ihre persönlichen süppchen
kochen und ihre rechnungen mit anderen
zu begleichen haben das heißt also da
sind schon sehr viele die die dort in
irgendeiner form versuchen sich zu
beteiligen an diesem großen game
innerhalb des landes lassen sie uns noch
mal auf die frage zurück kommen also
sollte man wie muss man mit den taliban
verhandeln fr was würden sie darauf
antworten also ich finde das wirklich
schwierig mit so einer macht zu
verhandeln weil
also bin ich schon von vornherein weiß
dass mein gegenüber sich an keine
abmachung an keine regelungen hält was
soll ich da was soll ich da verhandeln
bin ich von vornherein weiß dass er mir
irgendetwas sagt und sich nicht dran
hält aber so das ist für mich ist klingt
jetzt wirklich total absurd herr du
etwas was würden sie sagen
ja ich weiß dass das im moment
politischen möglicherweise nicht so gut
in deutschland ankommt aber
ich habe sehr viele verhandlungen
geführt mit lokalen taliban führen
teilweise auch mit der quetta shura in
der sie in quetta sitzend wenn es um die
durchführung größerer vorhaben ging wo
wir genau wussten wenn wir das nicht vor
im vorwege klären dann werden wir vor
ort in größte schwierigkeiten kommen und
dass wir sabotiert werden ich hab dann
in solchen fällen immer über meine
mittelsleute gesagt ich möchte dass ein
bestimmtes vorhaben machen deutschland
möchte ein bestimmtes vorhaben machen
weltbank oder vereinten nationen und das
möchte ich mit den lokalen machthabern
klären und dann hat sich in der regel
innerhalb der nächsten zwei drei wochen
jemand bei mir gemeldet wir haben uns
irgendwo getroffen wir haben uns wir
haben unendlich viele tassen tee
getrunken miteinander und gesprochen ich
habe immer wieder erklärt was wir da
konkret vorhaben und in der regel war es
so dass dann gesagt wurde ja wir
verstehen das deutschland will zum
beispiel eine straße bei kandahar im han
schweiz trägt bauen damit die bauern
ihre feld produkte besser nach kanada
auf den markt bekommen das finden wir
gut das werden wir akzeptieren und wir
werden wir garantieren euch dass ihr die
straße bauen könnt ohne dass wir in
irgendeiner form dort intervenieren und
das habe ich in vielfacher form über die
jahre erlebt und es wurde alles
eingehalten was ich abgesprochen habe
mit diesen leuten wobei ich manchmal gar
nicht entschuldigen wobei ich manchmal
gar nicht genau wusste waren dass ein
taliban oder waren das lokale führer
andere organisation aber das wurde
eingehalten weil auch dieses
berühmte paschtunische ehren gesetz das
passt nun wally dann doch durchaus immer
anwendung fand also in der in gänze kann
ich jetzt aus meinen erfahrungen nicht
sagen dass die menschen dort sich an
vereinbarungen die wir getroffen haben
nicht gehalten haben frau valerie sie
wollten darauf direkt antworten in
fahrzeugen ich hatte dann einfach eine
frage warum solche verhandlungen solche
abmachungen mit den taliban gemacht
werden mussten und nicht mit der
afghanischen regierung
torpediert man dann nicht eine eine
regierungsform wenn man dann mit der
opposition wollte ich schon beinahe
sagen meine ich natürlich nicht mit
jemandem der bezieht eine regierung
schwächen will verhandele und
abmachungen treibe das heißt wenn ich
auch mit denen ihr irgendetwas ab macher
heißt es ja nur ich habe eine abmachung
wie das auch immer ausgesehen hat ob man
da jetzt sind irgendwie finanziell etwas
zukommen hat lassen oder wie auch immer
aber auf jeden fall heißt das wenn die
damit d'accord sind wenn sie damit
einverstanden sind dass ich an mein
projekt fortführen heißt es ja nur dass
die dann man projekt nicht zerstören
ich verstehe das nicht
sie können ganz sicher sein ich bin zwar
kein diplomat aber durchaus diplomatisch
geschult ich wäre ja mit dem
klammerbeutel gepudert gewesen wenn ich
so mit den führern von aufständischen
geredet hätte wenn das nicht mit der
afghanischen regierung abgestimmt war
die ja nebenbei auch mit allen führern
der aufständischen immer wieder in
irgendeiner form im gespräch gewesen es
und das wurde immer sehr begrüßt weil am
schluss ja unsere arbeit den menschen
zugute kam jetzt haben wir sehr sehr
viele fragen haben sie beide im stream
und denen wollen wir uns jetzt auch mal
ausgiebig widmen also zunächst mal die
frage hier auch von ismael 04 nun hat
deutschland aufgrund der machtübernahme
der taliban taliban die
entwicklungshilfegelder für afghanistan
ausgesetzt was bedeutet das für die
entwicklungshilfe im land dazu hätte ja
das was ich gerade eben sagte das
bedeutet jetzt aus meiner sicht aus
politischer deutscher politischer sicht
mag es noch etwas anderes bedeuten aber
aus meiner sicht bedeutet das dass wir
den den menschen dort vor ort nicht
helfen können durch angepasste
entwicklungsvorhaben und das halte ich
für sehr schade und ich habe die
bevölkerung dass dadurch eher eine
radikalisierung eintritt
dann eine frage von kuki monster bei
youtube da an sie frau weil sie ja auch
die journalisten im land schulen dann
geht so ein bisschen um die frage ob die
taliban jetzt schon auch in diversen
bereichen enorme kontrolle ausüben und
zwar in wie weit haben die taliban schon
die afghanischen medien übernommen
möchte cookie monster
ja auf jeden fall also durch diese
einschüchterungen der letzten wochen
gehen schon sehr viele kolleginnen vor
allem gar nicht mehr zur arbeit aber vor
dieser ganzen sache bevor das auch ganz
klar ausgesprochen war zu welchem datum
jetzt die nato aus afghanistan raus
gehen würde hatte es ja schon in
afghanistan im überall in den
großstädten weniger aber in den
kleineren provinzen auf jeden fall hatte
es immer wieder attacken oder
bedrohungen an journalisten gegeben und
dann gab es bestimmte gruppen entweder
haben kolleginnen sich dann selber
zensiert und das nicht in der form etwas
geäußert oder gesendet oder
besprochen wie dies normalerweise
gemacht hätten einfach aus und sich
nicht in gefahr zu bringen einige haben
komplett aufgehört zu arbeiten und
vielen ist es auch einfach empfohlen
wurden von seitens organisationen die
sich um die journalistinnen kümmert
haben dass die auto vor allem so
berühmte journalistinnen die teilweise
sogar bis vor ein paar wochen in
afghanistan waren und dann das land sehr
schnell verlassen mussten weil die sehr
extrem bedroht worden waren und in jetzt
in kabul seit vier tagen glaube ich
inzwischen ist das her dass der
staatliche sender
normalerweise wurden darin die
nachrichten von einer frau gesprochen
und da sitzt jetzt ein talib und liest
verließ die nachrichten
und in wie gesagt aber in vielen anderen
fernsehstationen wo frauen gearbeitet
haben viele gehen gar nicht zur arbeit
einfach aus angst was ich am anfang
gesagt hatte dass sie ein bisschen
erstmal abwarten wollen wohin sich das
ganze irgendwie entwickelt bis die
wieder rausgehen um sich nicht in gefahr
zu bringen
wir haben aber auch noch weitere fragen
hier im stream gerade jetzt just zu den
hilfsgeldern da noch mal die frage an
sie herr dube galanti ass de möchte
gerne wissen wie will wie will wie will
man sicherstellen dass das hilfsgeld
nicht bei den taliban landet sofern es
denn also wieder gezahlt würde jetzt ist
ja auch zunächst mal von einem aussetzen
die rede aber wie will man das
sicherstellen das ist nicht so
sonderlich kommt fiat da ja die gelder
nicht an die regierung gegeben werden
damit auch nicht an die taliban also die
die reinen entwicklungshilfegelder
sondern sie landen bei der gez
gesellschaft für internationale
zusammenarbeit dass es die staatlichen
durchführungsorganisationen für
entwicklungshilfe in der ganzen welt und
wir haben oder die gez hat vor ort ein
büro und sozusagen aus dem büro heraus
über die lokalen experten in den im
ländlichen bereich oder in den
innenstädten fließt das geld dann
sozusagen in vorhaben hinein und wird
dann von uns auch oder von meinen
kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin da
nicht mehr dabei kontrolliert also das
musste mal unterbrechen abhängig vom
rückwind dieser stelle hätte wohl weil
jetzt gerade hören wir ja jeden tag
meldungen einfach von menschen die
ausgeflogen werden oder werden wollen
noch viel mehr also wahnsinnig viele
ortskräfte die aus lauter panik das land
verlassen wollen und eben auch
internationale hilfsorganisationen die
nicht mehr vor ort sind was tun also nun
wenn niemand mehr da das
ja wobei ich sagen muss dass der
größte teil der gez mit denen ich
kontakt habe der afghanischen gez das
land nicht verletzt sondern da bleiben
und abwarten weil sie auch sagen das ist
mein land es wird schwer für mich in
deutschland überhaupt fuß zu fassen ich
habe kompetenzen die hierbei dieses land
perfekt sind also in der größte teil
meiner ehemaligen mitarbeiterin
mitarbeiter mitarbeiterinnen sind das
ist eine andere andere klasse
diese bleiben im land
frau barbara wir haben dazu aber auch
nochmal hier fragen bei youtube da würde
ich sie gerne fragen jetzt eben auch
just zu diesen menschen die also
ausgeflogen werden wollen weil es gibt
also auch wir sehen diese chaotischen
szenen vom flughafen jeden tag sehr
viele die das also möchten da möchte
jemand gerne wissen und zwar thorsten
lensing was denken sie wie viele
menschen das dann am ende tatsächlich
sind die raus wollen das ist ja was
glauben sie ja ich meine sie haben die
bilder vom flughafen in kabul gesehen
und es gibt augenzeugen die sagen ganz
kabul ist am flughafen und will raus in
einem das ist man muss sich das
irgendwie so vorstellen wirklich das ist
ein trauma was die menschen im moment
erleben etwas was vorbei war etwas was
sie
irgendwie so
teilweise gar nicht die jugendlichen in
afghanistan über 50 60 prozent die haben
das ja noch nicht mal erlebt die sind
wirklich anfang 20 die wahren säuglinge
als die taliban an der macht waren
alle wollen raus weil alle befürchten im
moment das schlimmstenfalls ein
bürgerkrieg ausbricht und insofern also
die zahl derer die raus wollen ist enorm
also sehr viele sehr viele auf jeden
fall auf jeden fall die die am
gefährlichsten sind die mit den
ausländischen mit den internationalen
zusammengearbeitet haben und da sind
natürlich viele leute die die lokale
kräfte die für die gez in afghanistan
oder bmz gearbeitet haben aber
auch selbst wenn die jetzt sagen die
sind ab dann die wollen für ihr land
kämpfen und da bleiben und da haben wir
in zukunft
das lassen wir mal so jetzt stehen auf
jeden fall die werden nicht arbeiten
können die sind gefährdet wenn jemand
das rauskriegt dass die mit
internationalen zusammengearbeitet haben
fragt bin mit sicherheit kein mensch
warum bist du nicht abgehauen ist dir
dein land wichtig dann tu ich dir nichts
also dass das nein so ist es nicht
wir müssen langsam zum ende kommen und
da aber wollen wir eben stichwort
zukunft also auch noch mal in die
zukunft blicken also was ist da von
ihnen beiden auch die einschätzung also
was ist ihre prognose und auch so ein
bisschen was muss passieren eigentlich
wie kann man diesem land jetzt noch
helfen ich möchte mit hände beginnen und
dann frau barbara
es ist die große glaskugel in die wir
natürlich alle schauen aber
ich wage die these dass es gelingen kann
den diplomaten der westlichen
welt in gesprächen mit den führern der
taliban das so auszuhandeln erstens dass
die menschen die raus wollen raus dürfen
und zum zweiten dass es auch gelingt
dass wir mit wieder mit einer sinnvollen
für die menschen
sinnvolle entwicklungszusammenarbeit
staaten dass das möglich sein kann
meine große unsicherheit ist jetzt bei
dieser prognose ich kann noch nicht
einschätzen wie die ganzen kräfte so
früher hätte man gesagt nordallianz da
gibt es ja doch etliche leute den mann
den du im dunkeln auch lieber nicht
begegnen möchte wie die jetzt damit
umgehen dass sozusagen der afghanistan
kuchen erstmal von den taliban
übernommen wurde die auch ihre anteile
haben wollen die waffenlager sind voll
bei allen dass es nicht dann doch wieder
zu einem schrecklichen bürgerkrieg kommt
wie nach dem abzug der sowjets
1989 da ja dazu geführt hat dass das
land wirklich in schutt und asche gelegt
wurde und
diejenigen die dafür verantwortung tun
mussten dann 1995 96 zurücktreten wurden
dann aber alle letztlich wieder durch
die staatengemeinschaft nachdem wir 2001
dort rein ging in ministerposten
gebracht die bevölkerung hat sich etwas
verwundert die augen gerieben und hat
gesagt nun sind die an der macht die und
das land vor zerstört haben ich hoffe
dass es nicht wieder in eine solche
situation eines solchen bürgerkrieges
kommt
das wäre dann tatsächlich eine sehr
düstere aussicht frau barbara was denken
sie wenn sie jetzt auf die aktuelle
situation blicken was glauben sie für
die zukunft für dieses land
also ich kann jetzt nur hoffen wirklich
wie auch immer ist ich bin jetzt keine
politikerin aber dass die internationale
gemeinschaft sich wirklich zusammensitzt
und da was überlegt man ist nach
afghanistan mit einer mission
reingegangen die ganz am anfang gar
nicht klar war aber immer deutlicher
wurde welches ist und man hat dem land
den menschen vor allem den menschen
hatte man darf wirklich durch diese
ganzen politik und diese ganze
wirtschaft die menschen die einfachen
menschen die einfach in frieden in ruhe
mit ihren familien leben und da sein
wollen an die denken die darf man nicht
vergessen und das einfach dass man sich
mal etwas überlegt weil der westen hat
definitiv finde ich eine moralische
verpflichtung für afghanistan was man
übernommen hat und sich jetzt einfach
aus der affäre stellt
vielen dank iba burri dass sie sich zeit
genommen haben heute abend und auch an
sie hans-hermann dube vielen dank dass
sie heute beide bei uns zu gast war und
natürlich auch vielen dank an euch für
das interesse für eure fragen und dass
sie eingeschaltet habt und wir schauen
natürlich auch weiter für euch auf die
aktuelle lage in afghanistan und gehen
jederzeit live wenn etwas passiert bis
dahin danke und tschüss